hi there steve here uh if you like my
videos please subscribe i want to talk
about patterns how important they are
to
being able to speak comfortably easily
naturally in a in a foreign language
it's the key you have to master these
patterns and i find that you master them
best through lots of exposure lots of
repetition and paying attention and not
asking too many questions
and the reason i come to this is because
i have a video series with hana
for
koreans who are learning english and
i'll leave a link here in the
description box
and hannah asked why in english do we
say go home rather than go to home
or at home rather than at the home
and she had found an explanation that
said that in go home home becomes an
adverb whereas otherwise it's a noun to
me that's an explanation after the fact
what probably happened is that that
became the common way of saying things
and that's like so much in language
it's not a matter of you know because
the danger with grammatical explanations
is that you create the mind in the mind
of the learner that there's some great
logical mathematical logic behind
the rules of grammar there isn't the
rules of grammar just describe what
happens and so very often for example in
english where a double negative is a
no-no you can't say i don't know nothing
and they all you know a double negative
equals a positive and so they introduce
some sense of mathematics here whereas
in many languages double negatives are
exactly what is used in the slavic
languages for example
uh
in fact i often forget to use the double
negative
and then i figure that's good enough and
but i actually have to answer
you have to double negative and there's
no logic that's just how things are done
and in the slavic languages
oh and by the way i'm learning greek
right now but
the month of june is going to be my
slavic month i'm gonna be in bratislava
for the polyglot conference
and then i will be in ukraine for about
three weeks and all but in between i
have to go to vienna on business so then
i'm gonna concentrate on my slavic
languages which are still jumbled around
in my brain
also by the way for our miniseries we
need more
volunteers if possible to translate and
record in polish czech ukrainian
romanian hungarian in other words the
languages of that area that surround
bratislava but getting back to patterns
so
we develop these habits when we're with
one language through a lot of listening
and reading and then if we go to a
related language where the pattern is
different it's sometimes difficult i
found it difficult after doing czech and
ukrainian
polish then i go back to russian
and russian uses the verb to be is a lot
less than these other languages
there are there are many people
this book not this is a book
and
in czech and polish uh
for the verb to be is
they have a plural there are you know
they are they those people are
but in in russian they often leave the
is out
or in uh
ukrainian they only have the singular
they don't have the plural so as you're
in now sort of a slavic
pattern
mood and then you come across these
differences from one language to another
it sometimes throws you off
and this can happen in other languages
like in
in portuguese where they have this
personal infinitive
personal portuguese that reminds me we
would like some more volunteers for
european portuguese to record in
european portuguese we have lots for
brazilian portuguese if you're watching
and you're a speaker of
european portuguese please let me know
at any rate in portuguese they have this
personal infinitive which kind of
replaces the subjunctive to some extent
and that doesn't exist in spanish but
what i'm finding now very interesting in
greek
is that
this idea that you have like
i intend to go
so in english
uh to go as the infinitive
but uh
in uh
greek
the the you know the second verb
i intend to i go it's personalized and
the same if i remember correctly was
true in romanian
so you have these patterns so so what
might seem illogical and unlikely to
make sense in language a
absolutely makes sense in language b and
i imagine the varieties of these
potential patterns
is is very large and so really what we
have to do is not rely on any quote
logical explanation but just get used to
the pattern and i think that's best done
through a lot of listening and reading
and speaking and when you speak you
discover
where you thought you knew something and
then you don't and you go back to your
listening and reading and there's this
constant repetition of that same sort of
circular process
uh but but ultimately we have to get to
where we can use these patterns because
we've saved phrases and we've studied
phrases and we use them often enough
that they start to come out naturally
and i think that is the great advantage
of these many stories by the way the
swedish and russian first five lessons
are up at link and we're expecting more
and more all the time and by the time we
have a hundred of these
and they're fairly simple
and you need to spend your whole time on
those but it's kind of a place to go
back and practice and practice the
patterns the basic patterns of the
language and then go back to exploring
things that might be
more interesting so just to stress again
the importance of patterns in language
learning thank you for listening bye for
now
[Music]
you